it's not enough to know what you want
you have to to do what you want to be
what you want I read things that I feel
and then when the books are out people
identify themselves if my books I don't
imagine myself sitting my apartment
revision anything oh I want to be such a
successful writer and people had to read
my book when you want something the
whole universe will conspire for you to
have it
he's a Brazilian lyricist and novelist
his novel The Alchemist has been
translated into 80 languages he sold
over 200 million copies of his books and
is the all-time best-selling Portuguese
author he's Paulo Coelho and here's my
take on his top 10 rules for success
rule number one is my personal favorite
and make sure to sticker on all the way
to the end for some special bonuses and
as you watch the clips that there's
something that Paulo says that really
resonates with you make sure to put it
in the comments in quotes so that other
people can benefit and be inspired as
well you know it took me years I knew
that I want to be a writer since I was
young and have this megalomaniac things
about being the most famous writer the
world but it's not enough to know what
you want you have to to do what you want
to be what you want you know so a writer
implies in writing books yeah a gardener
implies in gardens you know but if you I
don't know about today but if you talked
to your father your mother if you are
from a middle-class I want to be a
gardener a fallacy oh my son please go
to the University yeah get a diploma
Miami can do your gardening during the
weekend you know but you love plants you
love the soil we love hello but at the
end of the day you are convinced and
this is not good for the person who is
being convinced it for the person who's
trying to convince you're creating this
order of frustration
around them your background is very well
documented that the things you went
through which have shaped you how much
of that is really behind you or how much
do those ghosts still haunt you the the
involvement in in you know issues that
got you imprisoned and tortured and you
know the drug use and so on I am a
myself and my circumstance I think that
like a Spanish philosopher uses to say
so Who am I am a sum of all the
experiences that I lived in my life that
said of course I don't look back because
if I look back at the I may become a
starter of salt so I try to live my life
here but it is the sum of difficult
moments good moments
well experiences that I had in my life
that brought me here in front of your of
this camera talking to you you don't
live your life in this capitalistic
sense that accumulate knowledge has
accumulated the money no no no no life
is about the present moment and you're
here you are here now and then you have
an idea we have something but that may
be a route in your past but you don't
know so what I try to do is to live my
life as full as as intensely as I can
you're one of the world's most widely
read authors but you're more than just a
writer you know you have you become
something of a spiritual icon how do you
regard yourself nowadays I would totally
disagree with you his I'm not a
spiritual master or anything I am
someone who is well walking through this
life I'm learning at the same time what
I do is to share my experience because I
think life is about sharing so in this
case I write I write things that I feel
and then when the books are out people
identify themselves with my books but
not if my answers mostly with my
questions well listen you I know you've
said that you have nothing to teach but
you have something to share but it must
put some pressure on you when people are
looking for answers obviously you're
touching something that people are
missing in their lives doing beliefs oh
well I
no I don't know I think that when I read
a book at trying to understand myself
because it's not easy to understand
yourself unless you share as I said with
someone else so when I see it
I have no clear idea what I'm going to
write about sometimes it is a totally
unknown part of me who does it so we get
inspirations traditional meaning and
getting breathing getting things from
outside to inside so my books mostly
they try to share to myself Who am I
because I misspoke a constant process of
discovering myself when I child they
think that all you exist right right and
one day I was by a orange tree and I had
the sensation that I was alive do you
remember the day that you realized that
you are alive no I don't remember the
day but that's yeah I remember so so so
I wish I did
okay so but that is my god I'm alive not
only I am Alive but I'm not the center
of the universe and then I realized that
I was alive and there was a lot of
things going on outside my my child my
childish world and so I said I'm going
to pay attention to what is going on and
and this is how I survive it I think
that you have to take risks all the time
if you don't do that you you don't move
forward we are trying to be too
conservative and the way that you think
life and the results is that nobody
voice off to say I don't agree with this
I agree with that so we have to push
somehow our our individuality to make
sure that our voice can be heard my my
personal legend was always to be a
writer and and finding a personal agent
does not mean fulfilling your personal
legend because being a writer means
writing books I cannot just see this
okay I'm a writer
so we write a Facebook it makes me or
not be successful then there's the next
one there is a third one and all of a
sudden I realized that you are your book
your books are doing very well and you
fear success you have this moment that
you think oh my god should I write the
next book do I need to be judged again
by the critics etcetera and then you
realize that your personal legend is
about moving on go if you if you had the
dream of becoming a writer write books
don't be paralyzed by either success or
failure so I'm in the process I'm on the
journey of my personal legend not to
fulfill it but to leave it as full as
intensely as I can I fought against all
odds there is no tradition of Brazilian
writer to be translated there is no
tradition of being published
I am published now I thinking 56
languages which is very impressive so
for example only ninja I'm publishing 80
different languages in in Spain
publishing in four different languages
so I couldn't never ever dream I could
well I don't imagine myself sitting my
apartment in English and anything oh I
want to be such a successful writer and
people had to read my book because at
the end of the day who promotes
the book is the reader why did my book
travel so well to such different places
like Iran and Israel my highest
readership per capita is Iran and Israel
they have a four point five every four
point five house in these two countries
they have at least one book of mine so
there is no recipe from the moment that
you try to find the recipe I think you
are lost because you lose the most
important thing in you that it is your
ex continuity I would also like to use
the word innocence
not in a sense in the sense of be naive
but in a sense in the sense of being
open at all seeing everything as a child
and be amazed and surprised at and enjoy
discovering life every single day you
are here to honor something called the
miracle of life you can be here - well -
for fewer hours and days with something
that is meaningless yeah but you know
that you have a reason to be here it is
the only thing that gives you enthusiasm
right you know yeah and you know when
you are betraying your personal legend
when you're doing something without
integers and worse you know that you
have this good excuse I'm not ready
which is just an excuse
no but no I'm not ready I have to wait
for the right moment
you know now I have to feed my family
come on
your family wants to see you happy yes
your daughter your husband your wife
they don't want to see you dear sitting
in a work that you hate right even if it
gives you tons of money when my first
book The Alchemist says start being
successful
I was already 42 so I was mature enough
to learn that everything is a gift and
you have to treasure and respect it is
as a gift and not to to be crazy because
you're successful so I had before that
that's a huge success time is very
difficult times and and I learned a lot
about luck coincidence and faith in the
alchemist I wrote when you want
something the whole universe will
conspire
for you to have it
this means that when you put your
vibration or your energy call it
whatever you want to call into the air
somehow this soul of the world is
affected I think that the coincidence is
the language of the Stars for something
to happen so many forces had to be put
in action according to the ancient
alchemists and to the physicists of
today everything is one thing only but
they will call it atom everything is
made of atoms if everything is totally
connected
whatever you do interfere in the rest of
the world
so science is when you look around and
you'll see oh my god the only verse was
talking to me I have to understand it
this language how can you understand any
language is by taking the risks not
being afraid of making mistakes so you
start to learn this language using
something that you deny it so for your
intuition and you need to use your
intuition and you need to be brave
enough to dive deep into this unknown
universe and say I'm going to learn
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Andre F asked me
to so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know which of Paolo's
comments the biggest impact on you and
why what change you're going to make in
your business or life as a result of
watching this video leave it in the
comments and I will join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Dina Harbor from women
obtaining wealth calm Dina thank you so
much for buying the copy of my book it
really means a lot to me those are you
watching if you want to change that a
shadow in a future video make sure to
pick up a copy of the book and email in
your receipts so we can keep track thank
you guys so much for watching continue
to believe or whatever your one word is
and I'll see you soon
what is inspiration it's precious
breathing right so you put what is
outside inside of you and then you
expire so inspiration something that
everybody has not only writers everybody
has while you or she why do things of
love it is connected with this energy
that we don't understand we can explain
explain explain but it is connected with
the energy of love if you enjoy what
you're doing you're going to be inspired
to share with other people
however inspiration you cannot guide
inspiration inspiration is a boat and
you are in this boat in a sea so that is
gigantic sea and your boat is taking you
inspirations guiding you in spirit as
this wind that is guiding you towards
your destiny if you try to guide
inspiration you're lost you can do it of
course but then go and write a technical
book what you need to do what at least I
need to do when I sit down to write is
to have another idea as a mess
in my previous podcast but that allow
myself to be guided by this overall
overall idea I go into this both of
inspiration sit here every morning when
I'm writing a new book when I was
writing a laugh normally I started at 11
o'clock in the morning and then of
course I had the ideas of the previous
night where I was upstairs in my bed
thinking tomorrow I need to write about
these diseases in this and I took a lot
of notes then I sit here I read this
note and I said oh let's let's try to do
this but I know it's not going to work
and then you start using our notes to
write the next page the next chapter but
the notes are not connected with your
experience or my special so after half
an hour trying to do this or that
I finally get into this boat because you
need to discipline also to go into this
boat and I allow myself to be guided